hi I'm Erik Bosse and Captain Marvel has
an official trailer giving us a look at
how the most powerful hero and Marvel
Universe will set an example for all of
us oh my god don't worry kids I'm pretty
sure the old lady is just a
shape-shifting alien scroll pretty sure
I'll explain all this Captain Marvel
backstory and point out all the details
that you missed by going frame by frame
throughout this trailer which has some
subtle aesthetic choices that give this
footage a whole deeper meaning boiler
warning engaged I don't know my own
predicting strength yet you've been
warned also this video was sponsored by
Dollar Shave Club stick around to the
end for details about an exclusive offer
just for you guys let's get started
[Music]
okay right away we see Carol Danvers
played by brie Larson blasting away from
this exploding ship now first it appears
like she's in an escape pod but it
apparently disintegrates during the
descent Marvel has said that when this
movie begins Carol Danvers will already
have her powers unlike some other origin
stories that we've seen but based on the
footage in this trailer it looks like
her origin may still be revealed through
flashbacks which we'll see you later the
story will also be set in the 1990s
which his trailer shows us by having to
crash into a blockbuster so ancient
along with a video rental store setting
the time period I just like this meta
joke of this new super-powered woman
landing on earth literally shaking up
the action movies that were familiar
with Captain Marvel was a fish out of
water on this planet but also a newcomer
of a different sword within this genre
of Hollywood cinema and just a little
background on who Captain Marvel is
Carol Danvers was an Air Force pilot who
gained her powers from a Kree warrior
known as Marvel the Kree are an ancient
militaristic race of aliens in the war
with another race called the Skrull more
on them in a bit we've seen the Kree in
the MCU before characters like Ronan and
Korath from guardians of the galaxy or
Kree and they do appear in this movie
and the older comics Captain Marvel was
actually a male who passed on his powers
to Carol who went by the name Miss
marvel for decades but the more recent
comic relaunch of the character the
really popular one established her with
the Captain Marvel name no MS in her
backstory and that's what this movie's
doing too so let's keep watching Wars a
universal language
I know renegade so to her su never
occurred to me that one might come from
above so in case you're wondering the
music that we start to hear in this part
is a track called luminous and
unstoppable composed by alexander
dmitriyevich I honestly couldn't think
of better adjectives for Captain Marvel
in this trailer and speaking of luminous
what do you guys think those lights are
the ones that are beaming onto Carol
back at the last shot we saw a flicker
illuminate inside the blockbuster back
from that exterior angle and at first I
thought those were emergency lights but
you can at least see that the emergency
lights already lit up so these lights
must be something else perhaps like a
beaming message or a warning from the
debris of the curry escape pod that she
crash-landed with and as we hear the
voice of Nick Fury we see Kara walking
through a Los Angeles train station now
as an LED resident myself I can tell you
this city ain't exactly known for public
transport and our train lines are pretty
recent but if you look closely you can
see that Carol is in the 7th Street
metro center station which she looked it
up opened in 1991 in the lower level 93
so the timeline actually matches up
anyway I think this crash landing in the
blockbuster will lead to a chase through
the 90s Los Angeles train and bus lines
with Carol as a sort of super outcast
kind of like the way Kat was in New York
let's move on
space invasion
big car chase
we're gonna here notice how the Marvel
Studios title card has been updated to
feature the red blue and gold color
scheme Captain Marvel No and then we see
Carole enter this shield basement you
can see the shield logo on her hat there
her shirt here has the logo for the 90s
rock band Nine Inch Nails on it which
feels like a similar throwback to Tony
Stark's Black Sabbath shirt and the
Avengers and for the back of this
basement we see what looks like an
autopsy on a Skrull corpse now the
scrolls are known for their
shape-shifting ability which they have
used to infiltrate shield just honestly
really bad it's securing itself against
all infiltrations this story appears to
be adapted partly from the Secret
Invasion storyline from Marvel Comics
and that storyline these scroll
shapeshifters pose as members of The
Avengers they caused paranoia to spread
through their ranks Tony Stark and Reed
Richards actually conduct a similar
scroll autopsy hi
overseeing this autopsy is a young Phil
Coulson more on him in a bit as well as
a young Nick Fury and notice how he's
holding a weapon perhaps just in case
this girl springs back to life and he's
holed in the ice pack against his left
eye it looks like this movie will reveal
the backstory of how Nick Fury lost his
eye something he did allude to in
Captain America the Winter Soldier last
time I trusted someone I lost it now it
could be that this scroll was posing as
a SHIELD agent whom fury trusted but
then took his eye out in a fight or
maybe the fight just injured his eye
leading to it getting bandaged up that
we saw in the recent promo photos that's
why Fury is icing it here but maybe left
it was some kind of infection that later
led to the eye having to be removed then
we get this very interesting shot of an
alien ship d cloaking itself over
Earth's surface I'm not really sure if
the ship is Krier scroll if you look
closely you can see that it does have a
similar dot lighting pattern to the ship
that the Kree star force forward later
in the trailer meanwhile the smaller
aircraft could be Carol and her plane
breaking through the Earth's atmosphere
I'm thinking that this could be the
moment that carol danvers makes first
contact with the Kree perhaps they end
up abducting her to recruit like a
brazen super soldier from Earth knowing
that this planet will be a battleground
in their war with the Skrull as a human
Danvers might be better able to identify
the subtleties between legit humans and
squirrel imposters which might be part
of what we're seeing in those LA metro
chase shots but more on that theory
later moving on subito
I was ready to hang it up to let miss
you today so you're not from around here
it's hard to explain in this clip we see
a young Nick Fury with Marvel's GA gene
technology working wonders on Sam
Jackson okay it looks like he's about to
quote the Book of Ezekiel at us from the
very first time we met fury in the MCU
he hinted that he's recruited
superheroes for shield for quite some
time you think you're the only superhero
in the world this isn't my first rodeo
mr. stark and his meeting with Carol
Danvers here appears to be that first
rodeo
he keeps alluding to and before I move
on we see a shot of what looks like a
Kree ship blasting down toward the
planet's surface we'll meet the crew of
the ship in a moment so I keep having
these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
here we see Carol on challah the Kree
homeworld overlooking a Kree city now
this clip jumps around across a few time
period suggesting this movie will
feature flashbacks to Carol's time as an
Air Force pilot before joining the Kree
so we see her in her flight suit along
with this other pilot this is maria
rambo callsign photon she is most likely
the mother of Monica Rambeau a name you
may know for the Marvel Comics she's
spectrum an associate of Captain Marvel
spectrum has similar powers to Captain
Marvel she even led the Avengers for a
period of time here we also see this
trailers interesting editing device
showing a montage of parallel life
moments that careless stumbled in effect
this is linking all of Carole's setbacks
together and later in the trailer of
course we'll see a parallel editing
device that links all the moments she
overcame these setbacks the idea of this
is is that no one defeat ends us one
stumble is just a rite of passage that
makes us stronger it's quote those Nolan
Batman movies why do we fail mr. Wayne
don't we collect a bit cost Rebecca pip
you look closely in the midst of this
montage can actually see Carole in a
baseball uniform and the team name is
the sparrows it sounds like sparrow will
actually be Carol Danvers callsign last
year brie Larson wrote a tribute to a
deceased Air Force pilot who trained her
while she was working on this movie and
she signed it Sparrow let's move on but
I can't tell if it's real so in a short
clip we see that Carol may be suffering
from some kind of memory loss perhaps
due to the Kree wiping her memory or
maybe implanting fake memories in her
mind maybe trying to turn her into a
Kree super soldier the way Hydra
brainwashed the Winter Soldier but then
it looks like the real memories of her
past life heed echoing into her mind
whenever she finds herself a new
parallel experiences this could end up
being a source of conflict between this
model soldier in her creaking Patriots
but a little Zito I want to point out
here look closely Carol's eyes there is
definitely something being reflected in
her pupils they're to me I don't know it
kind of looks like tips of spacecrafts
docking
i me know what it looks like to you in
the comments below in the meantime let's
move on
[Music]
we have no idea what threats are out
there
okay there's a lot to talk about here
first we see Carol Danvers with the star
force they're described as an elite Kree
military unit kind of like SEAL Team six
of space on this team is Korath Djimon
Honsou character we saw on guardians of
the galaxy there's also mid nerve doctor
Minerva in the Marvel Comics she's
played by Jimmy Chan Minerva is a Kree
geneticist obsessed with finding ways of
ending her races genetic stagnation
basically their society has become so
utopian that they're no longer evolving
another member is Atlas captain atlas in
the comics he's played by Bob Jenna's
Perez Soto as well as bran char played
by Runa tempte he wasn't a member of the
Star Force in the comics but his one
claim to fame was that he was a Kree
soldier who broke one of Captain America
shields anyway I think it's clear that
some major stuffs gonna go down with the
Star Force
for starters we know that Korath
eventually defects from the Kree along
with Ronan who's also in this movie
remember Ronan eventually gets disavowed
by the Kree society which we learned at
the start of the guardians of the galaxy
and something that's going to cause this
band to break up my prediction is that
this movie will pull from the operation
galactic storm storyline in the Marvel
comics that ends with the Kree homeworld
being decimated by a massive bomb and we
find out that that was actually
orchestrated by the Kree supreme
intelligence who hoped to cause
mutations among the survivors of their
own race and break past that whole Creed
genetic stagnation that I mentioned
before it's a super dark and very
watchman style twist Atlas actually
kills himself when he learns the truth
behind the conspiracy in this event or
at least the conspiracy to attempt this
genocide could be what divides the Kree
like Ronan and Korath from the others
maybe that plot is what leads to them
becoming these extremists war criminals
it's also possible that Jude Law's
character could be behind such a move
originally we assumed that he would be
playing Marvel that male Kree who
originally carried the Captain Marvel
mean but so far Marvel has only named
him as the commander of the Star Force
so we didn't know what his name is that
has led to some of us to speculate that
it could be jaan raghav Ilyn and the
primary foe to Carol Danvers in the
comics let me know what you think about
this theory in the comments below
let's also move on to this shot of young
Carol who's on some kind of runway
notice how this shot lips vertical it
actually matches the camera movement
from that shot of Carol as her memory
appears to be white from early
perhaps these are from the same sequence
and this is Kara witnessing her
childhood memories being stricken from
her mind and this cuts to an image of
Carol as an adult in the cockpit if you
look at the background it looks like
she's in space there at least in the
upper stratosphere this could be from
that Kree abduction moment earlier and
then we see the editing do this fun
trick turning the word her into a hero
neato we see the villains of this movie
this scroll they wash up on a beach the
leader of these squirrel is named Talos
and he's played by Ben Mendelsohn the
villain from ready player one in rogue
one The Dark Knight Rises
Talos actually shape shifts into a human
form and he infiltrates shield which
apparently has the security of a public
park and that brings us to my favorite
shot of this trailer where if you look
very closely Carol Danvers assaults a
grandma for no reason you say I'm
actually for a joke I just loved it so
much I'm put in the video no no no of
course Carol must recognize this sweet
old woman as a scroll in disguise
you know this movies all about that
night he's not styled uh so this is just
an Austin Powers River mother it's a man
baby you should notice how this elder
abuse is going down on a city bus so I
think that's connected to a lot of the
shots we've seen so far so if you'll
indulge me I'm gonna try to reassemble
what I think is this movies first act
but you don't want to know that much
about the movies and jump to this time
to skip it okay meet Carol Danvers gutsy
Air Force pilot she flies too high in
the sky and she makes contact with some
Creole ian's she ends up getting infused
with Kree superpowers and then she gets
brainwashed to join an elite Kree super
soldier team but then over time she
starts to remember her past which leads
her to break up with the Kree and return
to Earth but then upon getting picked up
by shield she recognizes one of the
agents as a squirrel imposter so then
she chases the scroll through the trains
and buses of Los Angeles until she
catches up to him poses this granny nice
try other scroll allies ran the bus to
try to help the squirrel escape but
Carol is able to kill him and help
shield identify the traitor in Frank's
or you know maybe Captain Marvel just
really didn't want to give up her seat
on the bus my legs are tired too let's
move
we can't do this alone we need you
[Music]
okay in this clip we see brunnen the
accuser lead paces character from the
guardians of the galaxy he's looking
down at Earth from this ship now in this
movie he's still a ranking member of the
Kree society so maybe this scene is part
of Carol Danvers abduction he's like
locking eyes with her from his ship to
her in the cockpit I also see a young
Phil Coulson with most of the de-aging
effects here going into just giving a
more hair also I like how all shield
agents apparently make a big point of
dramatically removing their sunglasses
we also see a close-up of this pager
which Nick Fury keeps on his hip now I'm
assuming this is a nod to the Captain
Marvel pager that Nick Fury tried to use
in a post-credits scene of Avengers
infinity war but I should say that pager
looked way more souped up than this one
does I suppose it could be the same one
and just over the years Nick Fury added
a bunch of little enhancements and
add-ons to amplify its signal so that it
can reach wherever Captain Marvel is
hiding then there are these cool shots
of the Star Force on a mission
underwater with Carol's helmet in a
mohawk style that's similar to
appearance in the comics neato and if
it's not really clear how the hair
coming out like that wouldn't allow the
helmet as a whole to be watertight if
you look closely it doesn't look like
the star wars are using a similar
holographic spacesuit as the one that we
saw in guardians vol 2 remember the one
that glows blue kind of like a shell
over your skin that could be how they're
breathing here we also see the moment
that looks like Carol Danvers becomes
infused with their creep hours an
explosion that might go down after the
aftermath of her close encounter with
the Kree and once again the trailer uses
its cool editing device linking various
Carol recharge moments throughout her
life reflected in her closing fist now
on the close-up of the fist of adult
Captain Marvel look that figure in the
background of the left you know who is
Captain Marvel fighting here someone
speculated that this could be Jude Law's
character when he turns evil but that
suits black color palette looks a lot
like the concept design of the old
school shield suit so my theory is this
is Talos these scroll who has
infiltrated shield and Captain Marvel is
bracing to hit him like he's a granny on
a bus let us move on to the final clip
I'm not what you
okay so when Karen says I'm not what you
think I am look at the lower edge of the
frame her hair looks like it could
belong to a young girl that Carol is
talking to I'm predicting this could be
a young Monica Rambeau
Maria's daughter I think in this movie
we'll see Carol form a relationship with
the young girl in the 90s so that they
could bring spectrum into the MCU and
Captain Marvel returns in the present
day for Avengers for this final shot
shows Captain Marvel in her iconic suit
powering up in the comics this state of
power is known as going binary Captain
Marvel is tapping into the power of a
white hole which is basically a
theoretical opposite of a black hole
so rather than light and matter going
into it and can never escape this
opposite version infinite amounts of
matter and light burst from it binary is
what makes Captain Marvel the most
powerful hero in the Marvel Universe
actually in the comics it doesn't
necessarily make her more powerful than
characters like the work but in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe characters
relative powers have been scaled
differently so it looks like when she
goes binary her power might be on par
with Thanos in the six Infinity stones
anyway I expect the Captain Marvel movie
the lean very heavily into this whole
space-time component of her power notice
actually the way the title forms with
the letters Webb together with these
curved graph lines
kind of like the ones that depicted
astrophysics and gravitational charts
mm-hmm I've also said that the glowing
energy around her arms and body is a
similar color tone to quantum energy
from ant-man the wasp I guess if there's
a way to use science fiction to link the
micro side of the MCU to the macro this
movie could break her brains like that
and for those of you who love the
Captain Marvel Comics and were hoping
for a cameo from Chewie Carol Danvers
Kat actually later gets revealed as an
alien called a Fleur Caen don't you
worry feel it closely the poster release
for the movie hidden over there in the
side and the shadows it's definitely a
cat but so they didn't forget Chewie who
do you think will be the ultimate
villain of this movie Talos Ronan the
accuser or Jude Law's character named
TBD comment down below with your
thoughts and follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ e a boss this video was
sponsored by Dollar Shave Club we all
have our everyday grooming routines
sometimes you just wake up feeling like
you crashed through a ceiling and your
hair just ain't settling right well I
bet you didn't know the Dollar Shave
Club yes that Dollar Shave Club has all
your grooming products toothpaste body
wash hair styling products everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best ain't no idea to cover this month
listen so much times wandering through
drugstore aisles I can't confuse easily
so check it out you got your toothpaste
and toothbrush and this calming body
cleanser is great for soothing your skin
after Captain Marvel randomly punches it
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their daily essentials starter set
to new members for only 5 bucks this
starter set features three trial sized
version of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean along
with their executive razor and your
first Vox who received their shea butter
and body wash in one wipe Charlies butt
lights you also received their executive
razor which includes their premium lady
handle and full cassette of cartridges
and after their first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks
a month this $5 offer is available at
dollarshaveclub.com slash new rock stars
that's dollarshaveclub.com slash new
rock stars Oh also if you love Marvel
stuff and you've live in the LA area you
really got to check out my live comedy
show called infinity fan yeah I say the
word infinity a lot in it and you get to
see me and our good friend Tommy Bechtol
and a bunch of other really funny people
and personate all these nerdy
superheroes it's gonna be so awesome
show details and ticket info are in the
description below subscribe to this
channel for all the deep dives and a
Captain Marvel in the whole Marvel
Cinematic Universe and if you don't
subscribe I'll find you and you know
what I'm gonna do
[Music]